[Music]
on this Tuesday night on the run the
Ferocious wildfires threatening
communities in the Northwest Territories
I'm asking residents that can leave
please leave the only ways to escape and
a military reinforcements in Hawaii a
Canadian business owner's gratitude and
grief we're blessed you know my family's
okay the support pouring in from
strangers no rights no Freedom two years
into the taliban's Takeover how
Afghanistan is the world's toughest
place for women and girls
and Inside the Mind different Monarch
this is a printed manicure what a
Canadian Scholar's doodle Discovery
could reveal about King Henry VII
global national with Donna Friesen
reporting tonight for a Nasser good
evening to you thanks for joining us we
begin tonight with the Wildfire
emergency in the Northwest Territories
and the desperate calls for people in
the most at-risk communities to get out
while they still can coordinating
evacuations is challenging because some
areas have no cell service this map
shows how trapped people are becoming
because of the fires multiple highways
are closed cutting off the only roads in
or out that includes the town of Hay
River where the mayor says people's
lives are at risk if they stay
so there's no gas there's no food no
health or Pharmacy in town people need
to understand that um if they get in
trouble or they need help they have no
way of contacting
contacting anybody that could help them
Heather York's West on the destruction
and the threat of those fires
the loss here is immense fire tore
through the Hamlet of Enterprise a
community of 100 in the Northwest
Territories on Saturday nearly every
home and business is gone half an hour
up the highway the mayor of Hay River
fears they could be next we've got some
breathing space right now we had some
rain last night
however if things change and this fire
starts running at our community we have
no way to let people know with the
highways closed and cell phone service
down the situation in Hay River has
become desperate the mayor believes more
than 500 people have defied the
evacuation order choosing to stay
the only way out at the moment is by
boat or by air evacuees from Fort Smith
and Hay River are taking shelter in
places like Fort McMurray if you start
to imagine the magnitude of
of the loss if if there was scenario was
to happen right
the magnitude is Big the Northwest
Territories is dealing with one of its
worst fire seasons on record so the
arrival of hundreds of Canadian Armed
Forces Personnel in Yellowknife Tuesday
was a welcome sight the city has also
declared a state of emergency with
another fire to the Northwest just 20
kilometers away it's a serious situation
um and the city as well as the
territorial Government Federal
Government and private contractors are
working really hard on mitigation
measures protecting the city is priority
one because in the north large-scale
evacuations are especially difficult
with limited access roads and long
distances to go because as I'm looking
at the ground like you see
how damp how just wet everything is on
her Facebook page Fort Smith Town
counselor Dana Ferguson said a break in
the weather was giving her hope though
Smokey for now the community of about 2
000 remains intact even if its residents
have been forced hundreds of kilometers
away we have to come up with a new way
of living
so that we have a future for our
children and our great great
grandchildren to come
because Mother Earth right now is
suffering what's become a summer of fire
taking a tremendous toll Heather urich's
West Global News
in British Columbia more than a dozen
daily temperature records fell on Monday
as much of the province is in a heat
wave Environment Canada says BC had the
10 hottest communities in all of Canada
yesterday Linton taught that list as
temperatures there reached 41.4 degrees
the hottest temperature recorded
anywhere in this country this year heat
warnings are in place for much of BC and
into Southern Alberta in Calgary outdoor
watering restrictions are now in effect
as levels in the cities Bell River are
said to be at their lowest in more than
100 years
in the U.S President Biden says he will
soon visit the island of Maui after last
week's devastating fires that raised
Lahaina the number of dead has now
reached 99 hundreds are still missing as
search Crews have combed through 25
percent of the disaster Zone officials
say they're also working hard to
identify more of the Dead that have been
found
I understand that people want numbers
it's not a numbers game
right now we're at 99 souls and Families
so we're going to continue to do that
among those already identified four
members of the Tawny family including a
young boy were found in a burned car
near their home and the remains of
Frankie trejos who was helping neighbors
during the disaster he was found
shielding his roommate's dog
and as survivors griefed the loss of
their loved ones many evacuees are
desperate to return to Lahaina Nito
Garcia is on Maui Napier authorities
allowing residents back into town
pharah access to lahida was briefly
reopened spurring a Scramble for Access
through police checkpoints like this one
behind me some residents are still not
able to get to their homes which
survived the fire authorities here say
about 2 000 housing units have been
secured for those who are displaced
among them is a Canadian business owner
and his family
two of the dogs that got taken in the
ocean and one's got burns on it Canadian
Dawn Prestige has lived on Maui for
nearly a decade building a life with his
family and multiple businesses including
two restaurants a retail store and a
boat shop in Lahaina all of which burned
he says six of his buildings including
this coffee shop were obliterated I
think the wind was so high and the fire
was so hot that it's it just it left it
really left nothing it's pretty hard to
grasp the pitchers don't do it justice
Prestige says several of his 140
employees are facing significant loss I
have an employee and she's only 21. and
she lost her cousin in the fire and so
she's 21 years old and she's really got
to support five people and pay for a
funeral against the backdrop of such
loss Prestige says there's been an
overwhelming amount of support from
fellow Canadians I didn't even have to
go further than one person from Calgary
any wired funds today to to support her
we're blessed you know my family's okay
our house will eventually get back to it
it's we're okay Prestige snapped these
photos before The Inferno forced him to
flee it started out with just trying to
make sure we knew where everybody was
and that they were safe he says his home
vehicle and family all survived they're
now staying with friends they also have
business operations in Oahu he says he's
thankful and trying to support his staff
it's a community that I love and so it's
it's devastating
parts of Maui are in severe drought not
including these structures which burn
down Hawaiian Electric says power has
been restored to a majority of affected
customers hopefully once we understand
more what the state in the county is
going to do we can build our plans
around that you know to have a future
again one day
Hawaii's governor said the fires were a
natural disaster and it's unlikely much
more could have been done but we have
heard outrage from locals here they say
authorities fail to provide warnings a
clear evacuation plan and timely Health
from First Responders pharah a lot of
questions in the weeks ahead Nita gercha
in Maui thank you nitu
Canada's inflation rate is once again on
the rise reaching 3.3 percent in July
according to statistics Canada last
month's rise is up from the 2.8
year-over-year increase seen in June the
federal agency says the rise in July is
largely due to an increase in gas prices
across the country a continued rise in
food prices and the soaring mortgage
interest costs which saw a 30.6 spike in
the past year the latest numbers push
annual inflation outside the bank of
Canada's Target rate and gaviola reports
prices at the pumps as well as growing
mortgage costs tied to higher interest
rates drove inflation higher in July
reversing a trend of cooling inflation
in June when we saw that rate fall to
2.8 was like okay great we're we're back
into the range and we're headed towards
that two percent Target and of course
this does deviate from that Trend that
increase in food prices at grocery
stores was mainly because of prices for
fresh fruit and baked goods the Silver
Lining that was the slowest pace of food
inflation in more than a year and
airfares tumbled 12.7 percent still the
cumulative effect of sticker shock is
hitting household budgets when we
compare prices this year to last year it
might look like inflation have gone down
whereas for families for households and
businesses prices are still very high
the Bank of Canada has said it takes
many things into account for interest
rate decisions inflation the job market
economic growth that includes the impact
of higher rate rates on household
budgets and debt for now the majority of
economists don't foresee a September
rate Hike It Takes between 18 and 24
months for interest rate hikes to fully
Ripple through the economy and we just
had another hike in July so I think
September they're not going to hike when
they're looking at how they should
respond to inflation they realize that
there's some factors that they control
and some that they can't you know one of
the factors that they don't have any
influence over at least themselves is
you know the global price of oils the
price of oil is expected to moderate
this fall and there are signs of a
cooling economy already in the labor
market with a rising unemployment rate
and gaviola Global News Toronto
police have arrested two more people
linked to the shooting death if a
Toronto mother last month a 23-year-old
former Community Health worker has been
charged with accessory after the fact
and obstructing justice a 20-year-old
man is also charged with manslaughter
robbery and failure to comply with
probation Carolina hubner makarat died
after being hit with a stray bullet from
an altercation between three men the
third suspect involved is still at large
a 32-year-old man was charged last month
members of the military can now take
harassment and discrimination complaints
directly to the Canadian Human Rights
Commission bypassing the Canadian Armed
Forces internal process the policy
change is effective immediately and it
comes after rampant sexual misconduct
allegations including against top
military breasts the changes follow
recommendations made by former Supreme
Court Justice Louise Arbor's damning
report last year highlighting the
military's mishandling of misconduct
cases and failure to recognize its
culture of abuse a grand jury in Georgia
has indicted Donald Trump an 18 alleged
co-conspirators on 41 counts
oh man
cute
this is the moment an Atlanta judge
received the indictment over a suspected
plot to overturn the 2020 election it is
the fourth criminal case against Trump
but this one is different
these are State charges being prosecuted
as an organized crime case as Jackson
proska reports instead of a mob boss at
the center it's a former president
the sprawling indictment alleges Donald
Trump and his allies knew they had lost
the 2020 election and joined a
conspiracy to unlawfully cling to power
the defendants engaged in a criminal
racketeering Enterprise district
attorney fonnie Willis alleges the group
undertook 161 separate actions in their
scheme including alleged tampering with
voting machines slates of fake electors
and a Brazen pressure campaign on state
officials that continued for nearly a
year after Trump had lost I just
votes she doesn't have to prove that
Trump was actually engaged in any of the
activities that were criminal it's just
that he's part of the criminal
organization alleged co-conspirators
include former white house chief of
staff Mark Meadows Trump lawyers Rudy
Giuliani and Sydney Powell and a former
top official at the U.S justice
department I think many of those people
when you look at this down the line not
today but down the line will have
cooperated Witnesses and evidence are
likely to overlap with the solo Federal
prosecution of trump in Washington over
election interference Georgia could be
more problematic and chaotic with all
defendants tried simultaneously the
scope of her indictment is unbelievable
remember we've got 19 defendants we're
going to have at least 19 lawyers a
single criminal charge against a former
president would have been historic Trump
now faces a staggering 91 felony counts
across four different cases
thank you
through it all Republican voters have
stuck by him believing as they did with
his election lies that he is the victim
Jackson these are not federal criminal
charges so how could things unfold
differently for Trump compared to other
cases that he's involved in
well for a state-level prosecution will
play out very differently for Mr Trump
he will all but certainly have a mug
shot taken the trial is likely to be
televised and the key difference here if
he is ultimately convicted he cannot be
pardoned by any future president or even
by the governor of the state of Georgia
Jackson prosco in Washington thank you
for that Jackson deadly blast caught on
camera
[Music]
an explosion rocks a Russian city
a Russian missile strike damaged more
than a hundred homes and a kindergarten
playground in the Ukrainian city of
15 people were wounded including a
ten-year-old the city is close to the
border with Poland far from the front
lines of the war
okay
this video shows the moment a blast tore
through a gas station in Russia Monday
night at least 35 people were killed
including three children officials say
the fire started at a car repair shop on
the side of the highway I took
firefighters nearly four hours to put
out the blaze
a powerful explosion near the capital of
the Dominican Republic has killed at
least 10 people the blast happened
Monday in a bustling commercial center
about 25 kilometers west of Santo
Domingo dozens were injured in crews are
searching the debris which is still
smoldering in some places there are 11
people that are unaccounted for the
cause of the explosion is still under
investigation
rights removed ahead the struggle of
women and girls in Afghanistan since the
taliban's Takeover
[Music]
Taliban is celebrating two years since
U.S led troops were forced out of
Afghanistan armed soldiers and
supporters waved flags and blasted music
in the streets but women and girls were
far from public View
in the first press conference after the
Takeover the Taliban claimed women would
be very active in its Society of course
that didn't happen and the lives and
hopes of women and girls have shrunk
even more today in the final part of our
series on life under the
talibanesh looks at what it's like to be
a woman in Afghanistan
education is a red line that is their
protest Chan
led the demonstration Afghan woman
marching against the taliban's brutal
regime and rescuing their lives and the
process
Taliban fighters have threatened us she
says beaten us with a sex and their guns
since season powered the Taliban has
deprived more than two and a half
million girls of an education
including sai's daughter
she is kept to Pakistan with her two
children
as John Mayer has in the past two years
women have been removed from society she
said we have a country in this world
where women and girls can't go to school
in 2023 when asked if girls would ever
be allowed to return to the classroom a
Taliban a Spoke person refused to answer
domestic issues belong to Afghanistan he
says women are not only banned from
learning they are forbidden from most
jobs even for Aid organizations in a
country graped by extreme poverty and
facing a humanitarian crisis women are
banned from public places like parks and
last month the Taliban ordered beauty
salon shut down this is all women who
are losing one of the only spaces that
was left that was available to them
where they could go and speak with other
women get advice get support getting
support in Pakistan is difficult for say
she is a widow and is struggling to find
work the Taliban killed her husband a
former member of the Afghan Air Force I
don't feel safe here she says the United
Nations estimates it will take 300 years
to regener equality around the world
since there are still some places on
Earth like Afghanistan where women are
being erased from public life
Global News
Ottawa
[Music]
regrets I've had a few next to what
newly discovered Doodles tell us about
the mindset of one of the most brutal
monarchs in history
[Music]
a koala named Matilda is sticking with
the home team predicting Australia will
triumph over England in the FIFA Women's
World Cup semi-final and she since
proven to be a good luck charm after
successfully predicting wins over both
Denmark and the round of 16 and France
in the quarterfinals
an Ottawa Professor has made a
remarkable Discovery that's filling in
some blanks about an Infamous King Henry
VIII historians have long poured over
his Reign including the lives and deaths
of his Six Wives it turns out academics
miss something the Monarch left behind
something that went undetected for five
centuries Sharia Israel explains
in the life of Britain's most notorious
King it seemed everything had already
been written Henry is enthroned here
looking very uh confident for 500 years
part of the story remained Untold until
Carlton Professor Micheline white
stumbled upon a series of Doodles I was
about to leave and I thought I really
should look at every page white was at
Britain's Warmsley Library researching
the religious writings of Henry's last
wife Catherine Parr then all of a sudden
totally unexpectedly I saw this little
hand the little hand or manicure is an
annotation seen here in a Bible from the
1500s this is a printed manicule the one
white found was faint but she recognized
the penmanship immediately these look a
lot like Henry VIII they were written
next to passages like these
turn away thine Anger from me that I may
know that thou art more merciful unto me
than my sins deserve it's clear that
Henry is anxious and thinking about his
physical suffering and he's worried that
God is punishing him for his sins Henry
is of course known for his brutality
beheading wives who displeased him and
advisors who questioned him we see the
paintings and the portraits but to
really get
a book or writings that tell us what
they were thinking and feeling at the
time it is very very rare through her
detective work she has shown that this
is actually Henry the eighth reading uh
the books that his wife his last wife
Catherine Park produced for white it
also highlights the extraordinary role
of par and the influence of her writing
he valued this book so much that he
treasured it he kept it the inner
thoughts of an Infamous King now a
documented part of History tariya isri
Global News
Ottawa
and that's global national for this
Tuesday night I'm far right now sir but
before we go an update on a fierce
bidding war for one-of-a-kind costume
this Donaire suit was created in 2015
for the Alberta Government for a traffic
safety campaign that was eventually
scrapped but the province put it up for
auction the winner of the appetizing
attire Edmonton restaurant chain Prime
Time Donaire and poutine paying sixteen
thousand twenty five dollars until
tomorrow take care of yourselves and
take care of each other good night
thank you
[Music]
foreign